in this lesson we're going to talk about
how does changing variables affect the
outcome
so in this lesson we're going to talk
about is you know when you change a
variable or multiple variables you know
how does it affect the end result we go
through two examples these examples you
know are basically modeled off of
previous act
questions that are similar to this i try
to make up some similar type examples so
you can see how this concept works
go ahead and pause the video see if you
can solve these on your own number one
says if l equals m plus 2n minus 3p
how does l change right if n decreases
by 1
and p increases by 2. and we've got some
multiple choice answers here does it
increase by 1 decrease by 1 decrease by
4 or decrease by 8.
okay well let's take a look well you can
see that if n decreases by 1 i'm just
going to put minus 1 here and p
increases by 2. i'm going to put plus 2
here
but notice what's happening see n is
being multiplied by two it's being
doubled so what actually happens even
though you're decreasing it by one two
times negative one is negative two
over here we've got minus three which is
like a negative three if this is going
up by two we've got negative three times
2 that's a negative 6. so overall we've
got negative 2 minus 6
l is actually going down by negative 8.
so the best answer here is going to be
letter d it decreases by 8. now is there
another way you can do this problem sure
you know you could pick some values for
m n and p you know like say m is one and
n is two and p is three and then see
what happens if you you know decrease n
by one and uh add two to the p value and
then see how l changes and subtract and
like that but if you can recognize that
you know we're doubling n so whatever
happens here is going to be double that
effect and here we're whatever we're
doing we're actually multiplying that by
that negative 3 that's going to be the
factor we add those together that's
going to give the net result there the
end effect on l
let's look at another example so in
example two
it says given this formula here that r
equals the cube root of v over two
how many times does v have to increase
right
to double the value of r
okay well there's a couple different
ways to do this problem one way to do it
is to realize that hey whatever we do to
v we're going to be taking the cube root
of that okay that's going to be making
the quantity smaller so in order to make
r double we're going to have to make v
actually eight times larger because
what's the cube root of eight cube root
of eight is two now another way to do
this is you can cube both sides so if we
cube both sides that's gonna give you r
cubed
okay equals
uh
v over two right and then what we can do
is we can then multiply
both sides by 2 okay like this and we
can get the volume or not the volume
just the v value in terms of the r value
and we can say
you know what would what would i have to
do to v in order to get r to be you know
double but essentially what we're doing
is we're just looking at this equation
and saying hmm whatever i do to this
quantity it's going to be cube rooted so
if i want to make this double this
actually has to be 8 times larger
because the cube root of 8 is 2. so
again this is a good concept to
understand and you can do it by picking
just some sample values and you know and
testing like that but it's good to just
realize that hey you know
what is happening here you know my am i
doubling am i tripling my cube rooting
and what effect does that have on the
end result i'll see you in the next
lesson